war zone Kings 39 gladiators in this one
1819 is the average rating time handicap
30 minutes of fast chests double the
points and don't hang pieces whatever
you do do not hang theses don't drop
your queen like you did twice in the
previous tournament whatever you do and
now I want to target this pun I also
want to stop mr. Mouse clicking Bishop
c4 I'm okay with double pawns
my darks red Bishop becomes an animal a
beast he becomes a beast let's kick that
night away and then grab this pawn if
Queen here oh what's going on with that
okay I could throw in a check or
something watch out for the tricky
checks right here and then check here
get out there Knight is the queen gonna
play here okay I can't castle so easily
I'm gonna go this way
pom push if here I just push in the 96
let's do this what are we doing what's
the tyre situation I should just push me
let's do it now forks hit that rook give
a check here just pin that rook am i
doing this should be a lot simpler
shouldn't it hit that Queen get this
pawn get this bishop right here checks
that rook is still pinned
I got no Knight Knight takes here our
rook takes here or something oh I got
the rook where's the main this has to be
made where's me this is check and then
this is mate no matter what back to
tournament 2 2 2 where is where did I go
I disappeared oh there I went that Here
I am oh here he is here he is he's back
for more he's back for more this is not
the guy I want to see very early on come
on move these are precious seconds I
just wasted 4 seconds haha
that was four second
that I do not have now because of that
silly little ah let's go here right away
just go here get it over with night
here's coming up this is a disaster
already I'm not liking it
get over here bishop that's where you
belong where is it
let's do this pawn push no no no no no
no clean trade no I don't want that
either
rook right here take the rook take them
you know you want to take them yes
give me that g2 pun uh-oh uh-oh
did I get him I get him back is he gonna
milk the clock he's gonna try to milk
the clock he's gonna try to milk the
clock he's like I won last time I'm
gonna try and do it again that's
understandable make me earn it make me
earn it
no back ranks don't you dare night right
here
no oh there's no back rank mates watch
out made on g2 still this is check and
then this is me back to tournament land
six six and a bunch of two's stay
focused now stay focused little pep talk
didn't know sometimes I just have to do
that give myself a little pep talk and
let me know it's gonna be okay here we
go
even when it's probably not gonna be
okay okay this guy is gonna give me a
beating if I drop any material for sure
is this the guy that I had dropped a
piece against the last time and somehow
somehow made it work give me the light
squares
let's get developed my knight wants to
be on f5 he's gonna fall in love with
the f5 square he's falling in love right
now f5 he wants to be supported the
Queen does not like having to babysit
the night I should have taken the pawn
take free pawns please take free pawns
c4 let's do a c4 why not looking for
Forks okay let's do this flight square
on a2
I got excited right there looking for
Forks oh and I really don't want to take
that rook because my knight likes to sit
where he's at he likes to sit where he's
at this rook is not too comfortable
oh my knight is close to dead it's uh
it's saved now kind of pawn takes pawn
okay my knight is kind of out of play
oh is it kind of out of play or what
Forks I can't take it though uh-huh that
was a blunder
what's the clock situation I'm
immediately looking at the clock as soon
as that happens and that pawn could be
taken again and this product to be taken
wow this is wonderful this is fantastic
right here look at my knight isn't he
lovely
oh he's seen better days forks forks
forks are there he he had he had um
watch out for the knife forks stay
focused now come over here weasel around
weasel around right here chase that
night away watch out for the tricky
Forks more Forks are right around every
corner
every corner watch out for Forks watch
out for Forks run over here where
there's no Forks right here
there's no Forks give a check get a
queen I'm in a fork again these tricky
Knights ah I dropped my queen can I get
this just give checks give checks
they're down there down at 0.50 why does
it have to be so close I must last that
one man my heart is racing again and
again it's racing it's racing
ah I just can't be easy it cannot be
just nope there's never a clean
mouse-click around never okay take the
night wow wow wow
I'm on the Queen twice double check on
the Queen double attack on that clean
here we go
what's the scoop Oh kitchen I'm getting
kitchen sink I think oh the kitchen sink
me right there and hit the resign twenty
seventeen sixteen twelve twelve twelve
ten a lot of time left
Wow four games in three games in three
and four games in and there's 23 minutes
remaining in this non-stop action-packed
reversal at the war zone chess Skype is
playing team black hair and support this
and my e4 upon f5 Bishop h6 seen it
before you will see it again remove that
defender remove them remove the defender
look for mates age 7 happening f7 also
it's hanging under the bishop for a
second it might be c4 or something I'm
just gonna take here watch out for the
what what I want to watch out for oh now
I got a Royal Fork of Royal one this is
a royal one isn't it hitting the whole
family pawn takes Knight takes
everything falls this is me the king is
weaseling around
oh no that's made on f7 the King had to
go to f6 back to tournament thirty
twenty four twenty eighteen twenty two
minutes remain twenty two and change
more open Sicilian war Queen c7 I'm
having flashbacks against music mathil
graph where they played Bishop f4 and
said no it's a no to that fishing pole
so that's an anti fishing pole Line and
well we're hitting it again age two is
on the scene how many times h2 again 42
24 26 around every corner 21 minutes
remaining dragon boy is he gonna go with
the Sicilian no the dragon boy duped me
right there he's like you think I'm
gonna go with this Sicilian but I'm
gonna go with the Caro all right I might
still have oh it's still here can you
believe it no it's not here just yet
it's here now though uh-oh oh it's here
again it's happening again right before
your eyes this is not scripted
these are unscripted variations it's
happening again I don't oh it's defended
again not again but it's defended this
time the knight is there cuz both of
them um I better Castle [ __ ] up here oh
let's trade Queens okay well I thought
it would have been a quick kill but I
miscalculated there get that night out
of there could we please get that man
out of there and then take on this
square how's the clock situation
do I need time burners get that night
out of there push here and then trap the
night is he a cook tonight there's a
fork there's still a fork there now
there isn't no there isn't I can grab
this pun grab that bishop first no no
okay yeah let's do this
they're gonna do this I'm just
recaptured Wow - even with time hit the
beep on I don't want to take this Punk
because then it just I run into trouble
it's pile up on him he's a weak link
weak link go after him pins pins pins
pins pins just take here take this pawn
I should have thrown in a check or
something
all right we're knotted up with timewise
where we going here I get this one oh
wait I have to win this oh okay I'm glad
they didn't take tana pawn up again give
a check
let's go rope get active pawn up if
there's a rook check get that King out
of here looking for back rank mates
maybe back rank mates a rip block that's
me that's me that's me back to
tournament 56:53 whoa
fifty six fifty three thirty the wall I
got to go up against the wall this guy
is probably a master defender or not
he's a quick resigner 64-53 30 18
minutes and change remaining 18 minutes
and change let's go with the Alvin okay
well d5 is I think the most common move
there and I'm gonna go here maybe I
don't want to deal with the Bishop g4
pin stuff let's try this let's try this
kick that bishop away he has to go here
no he's trapped he's dead he's a dead
bishop dead duck
you have to cash in grab some pieces
he's cooked no he's not
I forgot he could go to the corner
that's a good spot
okay he's actually long gone now there's
no darks for a bishop my queen wants to
be right here right there that's where
she wants to be that's her dream square
she's dreaming of it she's dreaming of
g7 right now let's castle this way and
probably get off of the C file since
it's half open my rook would love to be
there so let's get there let's do this
and get this pawn up here right here and
there's if I did that there's a knight
here
oh man okay this Knight needs to go get
out of there night he has to be taken
definitely otherwise Knight f6 is brutal
oh he's cooked cook tonight and now it's
a connected passed pawn but now it's not
Queen takes I'm on the rook though if
that rook moves it could be me
okay just push this pond I want to be
here this is where I want to be give a
check why did I give a check that was
stupid don't do that there is no need to
throw in that check it accomplished zero
nothing accomplished nothing we might we
might be seen that Queen oh it's
happening maybe it is happening
I could take here and then there's back
rank mate isn't there right here and
then back rancor five-point-seven enough
time they got a block this is a giant
thorn it's almost like worth a minor
piece in some cases it's crazy good to
have a pond that deep in your opponent's
position crazy good okay open Sicilian
let's do this
watch out for that be five square first
they're gonna throw in Bishop f4 no
they're not I have to make sure not to
pre move Bishop here all right well
that's like an anti it's an anti fishing
pole when you go with the kingside
fianchetto those of you that are
wondering how can you maybe defend in a
convenient way that's pretty convenient
ah okay let's weasel around my knight
wants to be on c4 what could be
disruptive to both the bishop and this
whole Queen side
let's get d5 in somehow let's open it up
I think I'm dropping a pond though or am
i I'm on the Queen I'm on the Queen and
then I take care oh they missed it I'm
on the Queen take the rook this is up
I'm a full Queen here
okay it's a little bit uh annoying I'm
okay with giving my rook up so I want to
get rid of this pond somehow I got the
bishop
all right got the night with my bishop
no what what's the scoop okay let's come
back here to defend rook checks and
stuff if the pawn pushes I'm okay with
that I just want to get rid of this guy
get rid of that pond he's a thorn open
up this file and I'm at night and then
give it check not right there watch out
for the tricky Forks there was a tricky
for Krait there Wow bishop here Queen
check here cream of this get rid of that
night
end of the night give a check give a
check here grab that rook pawn push
let's grab this and come back here
Queen Queen Queen Queen watch out for
stalemate watch out for stalemate just
do this anything time burners time
burners time burners back to tournament
102 6556 that guy slipped up I think
somebody somebody got him less than 15
minutes remaining
less than 15 okay what's this Center
counter Center counter with what I want
a clean side castle I think ya
discovered checks on the or discovered
attacks on the Queen right around the
corner
g4 g5 maybe Queen is running out of
squares she's having a tough time
finding a home right now the queen g4 g
v oh this seems so good right here I'm
not gonna do it though this this is very
appealing right here and now it's even
more appealing a deadly fork with a
discovered check to follow this is
brutal this is this is a tough one to
deal with here
okay this is this is rough now tough
situation no good solution the queen is
cooked and the rook maybe the queen and
then the rook and then get the last
piece involved back rank somehow let's
just take pieces get the pieces involved
ninety five less than fifteen seconds
for a black okay I just want to do
anything really even at the cost of a
queen anything I don't want any time to
come off my clock here even dropping a
rock okay back to tournament one twenty
two seventy three twelve minutes and
change one twenty two seventy three
seventy two 65 okay Derek again towards
the end of that last game Derek through
the kitchen sink at me sacked on h7 and
then he hit that resigned button alright
oh okay I'm remembering this now the
Queen came here before the knight posted
up on e5 and the Queen came here that's
not a good idea so that was that was the
mistake last time it's been corrected d6
get rid of that Knight mates ret g2 is
hit Queen f3 I back up maybe I'm on the
Queen again pawn push get rid of that
Bishop Queen here the bishops trapped
with c4 it's c4 it's cooked out of
squares I'm gonna hang on to the light
square Bishop and then open up the G
file how can I be assured that the G
file will open up first fix this pawn on
F and second attack it with my Jeep on
so this could uh this is just coming
with tempo now or just allow black or a
white to take that pawn
I'm dropping this but I just want that a
file to open up I get this if that pawn
pushes I back up my light square bishop
actually I'll still do it back it up
Queen here I have a its opposite color
bishops but I have the more active
Bishop okay this is this is brutal now
it's mate berries seem to be me they
resign back to tournament one forty two
ninety one ninety ah
Zack efore D for some gambit here up
have a good Center and could be having
something okay ah just take free pieces
that was a free piece if I've ever seen
one
was that a free piece that Bishop said
come get me come get me and I said no
ridiculous oh man that was a free piece
that was back-to-back blunder right
there that is officially a back-to-back
blunder
were they just trying to catch me in a
pre move maybe Wow I wanted none of that
Bishop none of it Bishop g4 you don't
want to take that guy you don't want to
take three pieces do you okay finish
your development get counseled through
your other look on c1 and kill that c7
pond let's go tonight here grab this guy
night here forks forks forks forks let's
do this come back grab that Bishop I'm
gonna take that there we go 95 is gonna
beam he's gonna turn into a big animal a
big animal he is rook is hit pond is hit
this pond is going down crashing through
seventh rank of pig on the seventh
happening
very soon it's happening I'm on the rug
twice it's got to go back here it's
getting kicked around clean is getting
kicked around clean is hit twice no time
mates back to tournament the Queen had a
block there 162 131 106 108 minutes and
change oh this guy since second this
guy's in second oh this is a big one
this is an important one haha this is
very important
this is very important you got to win
this one you got to win this one okay
give me this okay give me give me give
me give me take my night please take my
night still it's probably okay now I
should play here get the dark square
Bishop soft let's try it again
give me the dark square Bishop Syme on
the night oh it's very very scary right
here very very scary
Oh bad things about to happen but just
in the nick of time get over here before
you get hit with the discovered trick
watch out for the discovered tricks
LightScribe bishops no no no no no no no
I don't want to drop that pine he's a
good guy
pawn push pawn push recapture come on
Oh let's go let's go let's go I have f7
protected
let's guard this pun I like my knight
he's a good guy here we go tricks right
here
I have f7 still covered pawn push rook
here no I can't go there now
I can't move my knight okay wait wait I
left this pawn can I get this pawn
hopefully that rook is offsides no I'm
not even attacking that pun I gotta get
this Knight out of here
why does it have to be sard okay I have
this or do I buy the rook is take the
rook I have a free rook I had a free rug
take free pieces how many free pieces
are you gonna miss my rook is kind of
dead
I can't move my rook oh there's Knight
takes I got a pond how officer plucks it
Oh checks tricky night I just dropped my
ruck no no no no no no tricky nights
tricky nights you know you want to go
here check check forks works everybody
loves a fork tricky night tricky night I
just dropped at night no time they're
out of time that was important win Oh
180 to 129 if there was a guy that could
catch me it was that guy in second place
and now Wolfman is back on the scene
here actually I have um I have the name
screwed up though I there's another guy
who's like called Wolfman I guess I
could call them both Wolfman here okay
let's not mess around this guy will beat
you with one paw he will beat you with
just a single pawn on the board and he
will then laugh at you that was tough to
stomach right there okay
well everything is hit hang on what that
can't be right what I can't be right
either I've seen this happen before
though they were up this kind of
material last time even more material
than what they have right now hang on
hang on
King position take the pawn take the
pawn take the pun come on over here
weaknesses watch out here because they
are sneaky watch out for the sneakiness
come on over here is it gonna be better
over here King position can we get the
King doing something over here King
watch seed three would you let's watch
see tree get over here on the a file
it's fun on the a file ah they're down
on time now pawn push let's just trade a
little bit could we just do that okay
they're gonna take I want to keep my
Bishop right there right on this
diagonal don't leave it are you doing a
good job
right where you're at take that pawn Oh
checks watch out for checks I got the
rookie I'm gonna take the pawn
I hear King position okay
break this up break this up they don't
have time no time king position let's
come over here Primo's back to
tournament it down - OH - 147 135 4
minutes and change remaining 15 15 14 13
games in from the top 4 that I just
rattled off there Derek again 4 minutes
I think all three games I've had black
against Derek didn't I didn't I
are we gonna have this same set up we're
gonna have the same set up all right is
the bishop gonna get trapped last time I
got trapped the previous time the Queen
was cooked get this Knight out of there
I could have taken the pawn till Queen
e2 i trapped the bishop again Queen e2
it's trapped again if it happens now it
won't be trapped
it's a cubbyhole and I don't want to
take here maybe I maybe I should be
playing this actually Oh it's dropped
efore is covered twice and it was only
defended once right are they going to
move three minutes and change clock tick
no way
do they maybe get disconnected or
something they want to do a clock tick
would they all right I don't want to I
don't want to take here if I take here I
open up the F file they were just
thinking oh the kitchen sinking it
kitchen synced to - to 156 155 again the
wolf is back here looking for another
win
okay take that pun take him he's free
take this one age five age five kicked
that bishop away where's he gonna go
I want that dark square bishop and the
LightScribe bishop I think having all my
inner pieces off this again is extremely
valuable again I think this is working
again oh they have an in-betweener I
have a I have a sneaky move - okay okay
if the bishops here there's no
threatening this guy I think they're in
a pickle pickled are they pickled here
they might be pickled f5 and then push
here no I just want to take actually and
I am taking f7 is crumbling hit this
pawn oh I have to watch this I didn't
want to have to watch that Bishop here
and then pawn here right here right here
if the pawn moves I want that pawn to
move I could have taken the rook but I
have this it's a mate one threat I'm on
both rooks I'll take it now mate threat
mate threat the Queen has to block and
then it's me
no matter where she goes again recognize
this pawn he's a giant giant giant thorn
that guy on h6 he's more he's worth more
than just a point let's close out I
meant to close out there double the
points one minute 20 I have to win this
one within 14 seconds if I want to be
assured that it's gonna be a win let's
go Knight f6 can I get that Queen don't
let any time come off my clock here
please no let's do this
so if there is no nonsense so that
there's no nonsense castle my Knights
gonna get kicked ah does not like having
to be there in the meantime these pawns
are coming right down they're gonna kill
me
whoa whoa take this night pawn push oh
man is this scary why did I do that why
did I do that run here
don't fall for me do this
oh there's bishop check this is so bad
this is so bad right here is there is it
safe the term is complete
oh good thing I'm glad that one was
called I was running for the hills
ah man all right good games 242 195 177
17 16 16 those the number of games in
there for that tournament